how's um Rosemary's Peter pack today
we're gonna play a brand-new game cuz we
never done that [ __ ] before this one is
called string along so why don't you
scram
sorry so sorry strong along damn it
did that did that did that uh don't look
sorry I don't know what too much coke
cane I don't know much about this game I
know there's two buttons touch to move
and touch - alright so left well that
went just [ __ ] swell left leg I woke
up like tears ah my ass I think my ass
cracked you barrel you did this gosh
this is a small step for me actually
it's a dying [ __ ] step for me and a
small step for pro tip I got it yes all
the [ __ ] walk into the club like yeah
this is awesome
watch me barrels watch my fab why is
there barrels here why do people not see
the Illuminati I snapped my ass [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] oh this game is pissing me off
wow what is happening I'm twerking a
baby outside my anus I think I don't
know what's going on barrel make it stop
oh [ __ ] damn it I woke up like this I
woke up like - [ __ ] you what the [ __ ]
this is how fabulous people walk oh god
my dick
know what as a funny helluva this job
Lafitte kooky rubber there we go
I woke up like a key the [ __ ] -
what is it snapped seriously don't get
greedy well don't suck my ass bandaged a
bluff fifth quarter all right you got
this you got this man small step for
poets and a giant ass crack just oh that
was hard
alright watch out for any poorly tried
sandbags what deaf [ __ ] I woke up like
tears I woke up like yeah
that was a close you think you can stop
me barrels well think I got whoa oh that
was easy
first try [ __ ] again dos then simply
step on a lift and it will take you to
new places for free what the [ __ ] is
this kind of commercial Oh
oh I hate my life I hate it ah ah help
what happened
yes oh my leg what oh [ __ ] I can't be
comfortable don't worry
I always walk like this elevate that all
bangtong c'mon your son make it jab now
spin fun all right here we go
ah why whoa you see that [ __ ] pal huh
you see that [ __ ] I do that [ __ ] every
[ __ ] day act complete mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] lalala I love you baby oh la la
la love me ouch ha ha ha
ah ah ah what happened oh oh oh I'm 11
soon a miracle Oh sir
si senorita fill the Congo let me see
you move like you come from below BIA
boopadoo well here we finish it yeah so
easy oh my god
touch and hold what that fudge cake what
was that got you now you love Froyo see
this [ __ ] barrel
you can't touch you can't touch well you
can no actually Kate you don't have
hands all the ladies want this how many
ladies wanna barrel huh tell me one lady
that was like I want to [ __ ] a barrel
now you can
what are you don't sell my fault you
piece a barrel everywhere every game the
barrels just wanna aah
balk god I hate them alright I figured
you out barrels
whatcha you see that [ __ ] to fab for
school in the pool I don't know any
school that's in the pool anyway so [ __ ]
that's right you can stare at my ass if
you want to up what what was that I did
it I stopped it is jump somebody stump
so fab so fab so fab so fab hello
barrels are you this fab Nathan don't
talk to me
alright don't [ __ ] talk to me excuse
me while I keep being fabulous thank you
if you want to be fab you got to work
hard in school do you think I got this
fab just by being a [ __ ] peasant no I
put on makeup every day to look extra
gay I mean extra five [ __ ] whatever go
Bob go Bob go Bob nice Bob you can do it
Bob I have faith in you Bob
I invested a serious amount of time in
you Bob you piece a Bob that's right you
walk like you have pooped your pants but
damn I Love You Man
act 10 let's do this baby nailed it yes
this is exactly what I was hoping for I
don't know what's going on exactly
but I think my foot your but I think
your foot is broken Bob no you're fine
what now it broke you got a bounce it
you got a bouncy like you bounce on your
mama's balls what the actual [ __ ] did I
just say oh [ __ ]
I made it what what what no oh [ __ ] what
what wow is that hahaha pages is the key
to success not breaking your [ __ ] what I
didn't hey sorry ah I'm so good but Bob
just sucks my ass man you think your hip
and snappy but guess what your [ __ ]
yappy oh I went there went there Bob oh
[ __ ] my eyes out what the [ __ ] did I
just say sorry I don't understand how I
keep dying at this [ __ ] part yes
let's guitar into that cuckoo shut up it
up oh here we go
moment of truth one step for my ass
second step for my senpai third step for
Jesus and fifth step for fabulous fab ah
mother [ __ ] Wow
I am the bought a [ __ ] chair cue the
metal
was that cool huh was I cool don't thank
me
thanks dude to edit this that's all for
me for now if you can beat act 10 let me
know cuz I don't think you can do it you
telling me all this [ __ ] time I could
be playing with a [ __ ] top hat you
didn't even tell me god damn it
alright well like if you know watching
this video bros I'd really appreciate it
it helps me out a lot and it all goes to
support my hair probably don't know how
that works but I'll figure it out that's
all for me for now as always stay
awesome bros